there's one particular instance I want
to zoom in on in which you appeared in a
video with Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
and several epidemiologists for
Roundtable and this was in March 2021
that video was removed by YouTube we're
going to play a clip from it right now
and I want to get your Reflections on
what happened there
I think the lockdowns are the single
biggest Public Health mistake in history
I think the lockdowns have have as
Martin said have failed to protect the
vulnerable Dr Gupta mentioned about you
know not putting masks on kids that's
not effective not necessary Martin
folder do you agree in school there's no
no need for them to be wearing face
masks uh children should not wear face
masks no there's uh they don't need it
for their own protection and they don't
need it for protecting other people
either
okay I mean I think schools how do you
teach a child to read with face masks on
on Zoom or you know I think I think the
um the children develop by watching
other people and I I think it's
development developmentally
inappropriate and it just doesn't help
on the on the Z spread I think it's
absolutely not the right thing to do
so I mean the the Striking thing looking
in the rear view mirror is that this is
more or less what I think reasonable
people agree with at this point
especially the mask point I mean that
that became policy in Florida shortly
after this and
there wasn't some sort of explosion of
you know childhood deaths or deaths in
schools but putting that aside the
reason I I play included the mask part
is that that's what YouTube said was
their reason for removing that video
from their platform what was your
reaction when that happened back in
March of 2021
I mean I was incensed I mean Zach I I
had before I prepared for that event uh
that got where the governor had invited
me to come out by looking at the
literature on child masking
um and I couldn't find a single
randomized study that demonstrated in
fact there was no evaluation no
randomized value from Child masking at
all and the the evaluation of masking
the the high quality randomized
evaluations of masking of adults uh
preventing for instance the spread of
the flu had found nothing uh same thing
was for covet specifically there was
this Danish study this randomized Danish
study that found no ability of the mass
in adults for surgical Mass versus
versus no mask uh uh for stopping you
from getting covered no such a
significant effect
um and so I mean I knew that there was a
that there was no support high quality
data in the literature about this
um and I also had heard from so many
parents from you know autistic with of
autistic kids of hearing impaired kids
telling me that their kids were
suffering because of the of the uh these
requirements for masking so I was pretty
comp that I was right
scientifically when I made that
statement of course you're doing it in
public so you have to do it in a way
that's that's accessible to people
um and I don't think what I said was
wrong there certainly it's within the
realm of scientific discussion of you
know to have that and so when YouTube
suppressed that video of a sitting
Governor talking to a scientific
advisors in public so he so that the
public can understand the scientific
advasis for which he's making decisions
I was stunned I mean I thought I I like
I thought like good government groups
should be fair or that even if you
disagree with what I said at least you
want to know what the advice the
governor is getting right actually
public
um it's within the scientific bounds
like there's I knew there was scientific
disagreement about this uh although in
retrospect there shouldn't have been any
like it was really really clear that
there was no good strong evidence in
favor of the masking at all in fact not
even not even real even though the weak
evidence was not convincing the weak
evidence being like bad correlational
studies
um so uh I I I still I'm stunned to this
Zach I can't understand
um and you know the effect of it wasn't
that you couldn't see the video the
effect of it really was to defame me and
and other scientists who disagreed with
the government
about these masking studies the whole
the whole purpose was to say well look
these guys are friend scientists so
Fringe that it's dangerous to have their
views even up on YouTube
um it was and you know it's it's um
looking back uh I mean I blame YouTube
at the time I didn't understand at the
time that the government itself had a
had a had a a big you know sort of push
to try to get this kind of message off
YouTube because they didn't want their
policies to be criticized
yes and that that's what the heart of
this case is is trying to kind of uh
examine exactly what the government's
involvement behind the scenes was and
whether they stepped over that line and
where it's where that that interaction
starts to get revealed is in another
example that you were involved with
which is you butting heads with Anthony
fauci and Francis Collins well I
shouldn't even say butting heads because
this was all going on in you know
private emails that were later revealed
but this is a headline from October 2020
where Dr fauci says letting the
coronavirus spread to achieve herd
immunity is nonsense and dangerous he
said uh this version of this to several
media Outlets during this time period
um and you all uh John uh deposed uh Dr
fauci and I've pulled a clip from that
deposition where he talks about his
reaction to
um the the Great Barrington declaration
which was a a letter that you and
several other uh scientists uh signed
Jay which basically said that lockdowns
aren't working they're detrimental a
better strategy would be what you call
what you called Focus protection where
you try to Shield the most vulnerable
people from the virus as much as
possible fauci will you let other people
kind of live their lives fauci thought
that was a dangerous and nonsense idea
and this is what he had to say when
questioned in deposition about about
that time period let's roll that clip
for a second
as Dr fauci says letting the coronavirus
spread to achieve hurdy immunity is
quote nonsense and quote dangerous
correct that is correct do you believe
do you still believe that do I believe
that the Barrington
decoration premise of letting the virus
rip through society and infect people
leading to their illness hospitalization
and death
is nonsense and dangerous
I still do are you an epidemiologist
I'm an infectious disease person with
some pretty good experience in
epidemiology our doctor is Dr
bhattacharya an epidemiologist I don't
know I guess you'll have to look up as
credentials so your statement was made
within two days of Dr Collins's
statement to The Washington Post correct
right uh did you guys coordinate on
making those statements did you discuss
it with each other that you're going to
make these statements criticizing the
Great Barrington declaration other than
the emails you've already seen I don't
believe so but I'm not one no I don't
that's not a style to be coordinating
things but I don't know it's possible we
discussed it depends on what your
definition of coordination is and the
same time frame did you become aware
that the Great Barrington Declaration
was being censored in social media
I'm not aware of any censorship of of
anything like I said
multiple times and are repeated again
for the record I don't follow
what goes on on social media censoring
or otherwise that's not something that I
pay attention to
okay so two questions out of that first
one for Jay
just your
immediate reaction to What statue is
saying there in this deposition this
propaganda Zach it's absolute propaganda
so as you said as you described it is
the inaccurate description of what we
did said and wrote in the great branch
of Declaration we were not calling for
letting the virus rip uh and and uh the
evidence was very clear that the
lockdowns especially in the spring have
not failed to protect older and
vulnerable people from many many many
older vulnerable people that died from
the virus despite the lockdowns uh there
was the counter example of Sweden which
had which had better outcomes in much of
the rest of Europe and certainly much of
the rest of the United States
um which had not locked down they're not
closed schools had had
adopted more reasonable protection of
what making a priority to pack
vulnerable over people the strategies
that that that Dr fauci had espoused at
the time had failed and it had caused
tremendous damage to the poor the
children the working class at the time
in the summer of 2020 there were
estimates that a hundred million people
would be thrown into poverty worldwide
because the economic dislocation caused
by Dr fauci's lockdowns 130 million
people according to the world food
program of the U.N we're going to be
we're at risk of dire food insecurity
meaning starvation
the lockdowns were tremendously damaging
the health of the of the world and Dr
fauci uh rather than trying to Grapple
with the actual critique we had uh
essentially organized a propaganda
campaign you can see when that CNBC
thing he went around saying that we want
that he that he set up a straw man said
oh let the virus rip
um no that was not we were not calling
for letting the virus we were calling
for better protection of vulnerable
older people we were not taking
seriously enough
and it was dangerous to let the
lockdowns continue which unfortunately
we did
uh now and that and that deposition is
so interesting
um he denies initially talking or
coordinating with Collins even though
the language they used was almost
identical nonsense he says then he
realizes I guess that he's under oath
and backtracks right in real time you
see that in real time he says oh well my
maybe I might have spoken I don't
remember I think I think and and then
when he's asked about censorship he's
like oh I don't I don't read social
media as if that's responsive to the
question
um
179 times in that deposition he says I
don't recall
on basic scientific matters on on like
conversations and even when he has
emails put in front of me doesn't recall
I'm sure he's a very busy man uh but it
it Beggars the imagination to think that
he he uh who is a architect of the
lockdown policies that we followed
recalls so few of the details of the key
key uh key sort of moments around this
um I mean I I'm I was stunned watching
that deposition and I think anyone that
watches it with an open mind can say
look we were not LED well by the
government scientists during the
pandemic we got a back door look via the
Twitter files at kind of how the the
dials are turned to turn people's
engagement Up and Down based on what
they're saying that goes against the
approved message and you were one of the
specific examples of someone who was
Shadow banned I mean Shadow Banning was
uh kind of considered a conspiracy
theory but you you actually were
suppressed uh according to these uh the
the material that that Elon Musk turned
over
you know seeing that and especially in
light of what's been uncovered in
Discovery for this case what's your
reaction been knowing that there's been
a concerted effort you know from the top
down to
really Target you
I mean I I now know what it felt like
for the the like the people accused of
being communists in the 1950s like I
mean literally uh in Facebook I was by
I'm Sorry by Twitter I was invited by uh
Elon Musk to go see Twitter headquarters
and see the the database for my account
um and it had the words Blacklist on
there I was blacklisted and turns out I
was blacklisted the day I joined Twitter
in August 2021. what would cause Twitter
to decide that I was going to be
blacklisted in August 2020 before I even
I mean from the first day the first post
I think with the first or second post I
had was the Great Barrington declaration
and why I was put on a blacklist
um I mean it's it's absolutely stunning
and I don't think Twitter did it on
their own I mean their interest is to
get as many ideas out there as possible
their interest isn't to like Blacklist
scientists
um the the what happened here was the
government abused its power essentially
forcing these companies to to act to
spread the propaganda of government
scientists to suppress the speech of
people who disagreed with them
um I mean I still am stunned that this
happened in the United States I'd never
I mean I'm an immigrant to this country
I came when I was four I always thought
that this was the one place on Earth
where Free Speech was never going to be
violated and yet I find myself as the
victim of of uh essentially a government
action to suppress Free Speech actually
can I say one other thing uh Zach before
I let you go back
um it was really interesting watching
that New York Times clip that taught
with President Biden and then and then
and then it's seeing what the the the
the reporters asked Jen saki about about
these these violence Free Speech
violations
the newspapers have an interest in
basically emasculating the social media
companies who are essentially their
competitors
if the social media companies are not a
bashed in a free speech well that means
that you will you will listen more to
the newspapers that's the only place we
can get information from it's like in
the in the Soviet Union the the the the
government suppressed Free Speech it's
such a great extent that that people
would you know they would they would
listen to Providence to see what the
government wanted them to think and then
there were these Sama stock like people
would send out secret messages
underneath uh uh you know essentially
trying to like get with the truth out uh
person to person under outside of the
view of the government essentially what
the what the newspapers want like the
New York Times is to kill a competitor
so that these Sama stock can't go out
the people will get their official View
and then view that as as authoritative
um so what you're seeing here is like a
lot of actors wanting to suppress free
speech and the government absolutely
using its muscle to try to destroy
social media in order to get its message
out in order to suppress if uh the
ability of outside critics to criticize
it it's entire entirely anti-American I
mean the I mean I I was put on a
blacklist Sac the word Blacklist was
there in the in the uh I just I just I
thought that was something that went
belonged in American history not not not
modern day times hey thanks for watching
that clip from my conversation with Jay
bhattacharya and John vecchione about
Missouri V Biden a very important legal
case about the future of social media
and free speech for another clip from
that click here for the full
conversation click here